normally when I filmed these videos I'm
at the Center for computing history in
Cambridge unfortunately it is April 2020
as I record this and times being what
they are I have to make do with the
green screen but why simulate that the
same location I could be anywhere with
this right well first this would have
been a great subject to film at the
computer museum but also if I change
things too much it will break the style
and people don't like change actually
that's not true
people like just the right combination
of novelty and familiarity on that note
did you know that you can't name a file
con in Windows 10 I promise that's
related if you're running a Windows
machine try it right now go to file
explorer create a new folder call it con
co n the system is not gonna let you do
it you also can't name a text file
conduct text or an image conch jpg con
is a first name not a common English one
but it's a variant of Cornelius Conrad
Connor Konstantinos there are a good few
people who go by the name Khan so if you
try and save a photo of one of them
using their name on Windows you can't in
fact the system won't let you call a
file or folder calm Orcs print lists
come 0 through com 9 l PT 0 12 PT 9 or
not and the reason for that goes back to
ms-dos one of the old white text on a
black screen command lines that were
just how computers worked back in the
eighties actually it goes back a bit
further than that because all the
versions of DOS were copying the idea
from other places but let's not go too
deep in history in ms-dos Microsoft's
version of DOS all those little words
are the names of device files they wrote
quick and clever way of letting programs
on a computer interface with other stuff
printers keyboards basically anything
that you can plug in rather than every
program having to understand how to talk
to every possible device that job was
given to a device driver and that device
driver drove the device so Chrome
Commons didn't have to worry about how
every single type of printer works
instead they could reuse code that they
already had for reading and writing
files they just save whatever they
wanted to print to the right device file
wouldn't actually get written to disk
instead the device driver would pick it
up
there and do all the heavy lifting but
the programmer didn't have to care about
how any of that works as far as they
were concerned they could just save a
file something else would deal with it
and eventually that meant that if a new
printer came out with a new complicated
shiny feature on it the manufacturer
would bundle a new driver with it all
the old programs would still work they
could just save stuff the device files
same as they always did and the driver
would deal with the messy real-world
stuff and if you wanted a really really
basic way of using those device files
you could do it with the command line
itself if you typed in dir you'd get a
listing on the screen of whatever files
were in the current directory or folder
dir they were called different things
like that add a redirect symbol that
angle bracket and instead of the listing
going to the screen it would be saved to
a file but if you tried to save it to a
file called lpt1 the system would spot
that file name and instead of gone to
the hard disk your listing would be sent
to the device driver for the parallel
port the one that was labeled lpt1 on
the back of your computer the place
where you'd probably have a printer
plugged in so even knowing nothing about
how the parallel port or printer worked
you could just print the side effect of
that was those file names were reserved
you could not create a file called lpt1
or con which was short for console if
you tried you'd end up sending stuff to
a printer or something instead oh and
the really early versions of ms-dos
actually didn't have the concept of
directories or folders as we now call
them everything was just in one big heap
of files when directory is what I had an
in those device file names still had to
work everywhere which meant those file
names had to be blocked everywhere -
same with context because file
extensions were stored differently back
then and there is a direct line from
thirty-year-old ms-dos to Windows 10
each version has built on the one before
if you know where to look you can still
find the Windows 3.1 file selection box
from 92 in Windows 10 today and Windows
3.1 ran on top of ms-dos now there
aren't many Windows 10 pcs out there
with parallel ports but about there's a
few somewhere a Microsoft choses to
support them because of backwards
compatible
backwards compatibility means that you
shouldn't have to buy a new printer just
because you've got a new computer new
stuff should also support old stuff
within reason the trouble is that
different companies have very different
definitions of within reason
video games are used to the idea of
backwards compatibility
sometimes games for older consoles will
still work on modern ones but usually it
doesn't last too long
you can't play a PlayStation 1 game on a
Playstation 4 at least not by I put the
disk in expecting it to work internal
parts are so different that the designs
would have to emulate the old system
write a piece of software that
translates between the old game in the
new console changing the command calls
on the fly or even just create an entire
virtual PlayStation one that sits in
memory it can be done but the economic
argument for backwards compatibility in
games isn't great if you support old
games does that mean people won't buy as
many new ones can you just sell them a
remastered version instead and if you
want to emulate an earlier system you'll
need to emulate everything even the bugs
to this day Microsoft Excel thinks that
the 29th of February 1900 is a real day
it isn't 1900 was not elite year
turn-of-the-century leap years wrong in
leap years divisible by 400 but what
Excel first came out in 87 it was
competing with a program called Lotus
1-2-3 and that program had a bug where
it got that leap year wrong so Excel
copied that bug for backwards
compatibility and more than three
decades later that's still the case it's
in the formal specifications it still
gets that wrong because if Microsoft
changes that buggy behavior now they
might silently break some really
critical spreadsheet somewhere in the
world
Microsoft has always been the company of
backwards compatibility it's built into
almost everything they do it's part of
the deal of why a lot of companies stick
with Windows they will not need to
change their workflow you can still open
a Microsoft Word document from 30 years
ago in the current version there are
going to be folks out there somewhere
who still need to use a very old bit of
software or hardware the sort of thing
where the company that made it went bust
decades ago and for that to work it
needs to read from a magical device file
called con so Microsoft to this day
doesn't let you save a file with that
name cuz it might
to break something it won't last forever
of course at some stage old systems do
become too difficult or expensive to
keep supporting or maybe there's a
direction that the company is trying to
push their products in Mac and Apple
users will know that all too well new
versions of Mac OS often just don't run
old programs new apps even simple ones
aren't allowed on older phones headphone
jacks and get removed people like a
mixture of novelty and familiarity if
you change nothing people get bored and
move on to something else if you change
everything people hate it breaks their
workflow and they move on to something
else backwards compatibility within
reason helps to find that balance so yes
I couldn't film this video in the actual
center for computing history but at
least for a while
I don't have to go to an actual museum
to run old applications and games
catalogues of software and the documents
created with them can still be read even
if the exact combination of hardware
they were designed for isn't available
no one's expecting your iPhone to read
punch cards but sometimes a little
backwards compatibility can be a good
thing
you